SANDY JONES:
Afternoon, everybody,
and welcome to Cloud
OnAir live webinar
series from Google Cloud.
We're hosting a live webinar
series every Tuesday.
So you can check the agenda
and see a topic that's
useful for you and join.
My name is Sandy
Jones, and today I'm
going to be walking you
through Engaging Meetings,
making them easy,
accessible, and everywhere.
Throughout the session,
you can actually
ask questions using
the platform below.
We've got some people
ready and waiting
to answer your questions.
And at the very end,
I'm going to choose
a few to just do in a Q&A
session and answer live.
So let's get started.
Like I said, I want
to talk to you today
about meeting experiences.
And you know, at Google,
Video Conferencing
is a crucial tool for
how we do business.
If you walk the halls
in Google, you'll
see every meeting room, no
matter how small or large,
there's faces in the room,
but also faces on the screen.
And we produce, I think, 10
years of video conference
every single day.
And it's become a valuable
tool, because it's
allowed us to build our
culture, be more agile, and more
collaborative.
And so that's what I really
want to talk about today.
And you know, it really begins
with this changing enterprise.
And I don't think
that's any revelation
that enterprises are always
constantly under an evolution.
But I think the
current evolution
that we're in really
started back in the '90s,
and started with the
desktop computer.
When the price point hit
such a level and the memory
and processing
power hit a level,
suddenly every desktop was
enabled with a computer.
It really skyrocketed
the productivity
of individual user,
empowered our knowledge
workers to really work on their
own to an incredible capacity.
Jump forward about 10 years,
with the rise of the internet,
and we saw a new trend
starting to take over and drive
that evolution within
the enterprise.
And that was really
two pieces, actually.
It's the rise of the cloud
computing within the internet,
applications that were just
served up over the internet,
taking advantage of that
distribution mechanism,
and the rise of mobile devices,
a supercomputer in your pocket.
So suddenly everybody had
a computer in their pocket.
They were networked
together to applications.
And that effect really has
accelerated the productivity
today of, anyway, the
organizations that
have embraced these
types of transformations.
And we've seen the impact
that this second digital
transformation has
had on the industry.
If you look at the S&P 500 as
kind of an indicator of churn
within business, it used to
be that once you made the S&P
500, like in the '50s, you'd
stay on there for upwards
of 60 years.
Not a lot of change there,
because companies-- it
took so much work to get there.
Fast forward to modern times.
In 2011, that was
cut down to 18 years.
Even today we've seen,
in a matter of weeks,
companies can be in and
out of that S&P 500.
And it's because
of their ability
to kind of shed a
lot of the things
you needed to build up
over time in the past.
And so when you at how long it
took to get to 50 million users
for the telephone, that
was a 75 year span,
mainly because you had to
build infrastructure, make
the various telephone
companies play nice together,
and really get to that
point where it was
accessible to 50 million users.
You see, there's a demarcation
point there in the middle,
cloud innovation.
Really, that's where
we've been able to shed
a lot of that
infrastructure and seen
the rise of these applications
that hit the 50 million
user mark in almost what
appears like no time at all.
Spotify made it in eight
years, Netflix in seven.
Twitter took that
down to months.
And more recently, Pokemon Go
hit that target in 19 days.
So a real increase
or acceleration
in the churn within businesses.
And really what that meant
is that organizations now
need to think differently.
They need to embrace this
digital disruption that's
happening.
And so they're
turning to companies
like Google, the
digital natives that
have built tools that were
purposely meant for the Cloud.
And so we're working with
some of the top companies
in the Forbes Cloud 100 list
and bringing these tool sets
to them.
And you may be familiar with
some of the companies here.
A lot of them maybe even
predated that telephone
technology I was talking about.
Colgate-Palmolive
is a great example
of a company on
the S&P 500 that's
been able to go through this
digital transformation with us.
It's impacted their culture,
changed the way they
work remotely, given them
access to recruit and retain
talent that's more used to
working in this digital world.
And really, more
importantly, it's
increased the level
of collaboration
within their organization.
And they've done
that, like I said,
by embracing the tools
in the G Suite set.
And there's four main
areas within there,
creative tools that empower
your knowledge workers to create
and share content,
connection tools that
bring your company together,
like videoconferencing or email
and chat, and then
Access tools that
turn a Google
search into a search
of your entire enterprise
corpus and allow
you to surface materials
that you maybe would never
find in the past.
Lastly, that all needs
be managed and controlled
in a secure way by your IT
team, and we'll given them
the Cloud tools to do that.
But today I want to focus
in on two key elements, one
in the Create side and
one in the Connect side,
and that's the Jamboard
and Google Hangouts Meet.
So the Jamboard, you can
see my partner in crime
here behind me, that's a
digital whiteboard that's
really bringing the
whiteboard experience
into the digital age.
And in Hangouts Meet, a
videoconferencing tool that
really turns any end point,
a phone or a browser,
into a video conferencing tool.
And you know, the impact that it
has is incredible when we just
sort of focus on
the transformation
within your meeting rooms.
And it's actually two pieces,
technological and cultural.
And I think that second
one often gets missed.
Companies look at the
technology investment
and forget to see that there's
also a cultural impact.
And so it's not just about
swapping out the tech in order
to provide this
better experience.
You need to transform the
culture of your business.
And the two go
very hand-in-hand.
What you end up with is a more
engaged community of users.
They communicate more.
They become highly more
productive and collaborative.
And that results in
an agile business
that can change based on
market or competitive forces
that they're always kind
of trying to adapt to.
And so to make up this
toolkit, like I said,
there's the Jamboard
and the Hangouts
Meet I want to talk about.
But there's actually
two elements
to each of those, the software
side and the hardware side.
The software side, first we'll
talk about Hangouts Meet.
That takes advantage
of that cloud computing
to deliver a high
quality video conference
experience from really
anywhere in the world.
Of course, in the boardroom,
we want a little bit more
of a professional enterprise
grade video conference,
and so we've come out with
the Meet hardware kit, which
just maximizes the experience
inside of your business
infrastructure.
Now, we felt that
the whiteboard was
a critical piece of
the ideation processing
business in the
past, but it kind of
failed to move into the future.
So we brought it there.
That's what the Jamboard is,
a digital whiteboard that
connects users together
via the board itself
or via series of
applications that
enable you to create and
ideate from anywhere you are.
Now, the result of
implementing these tools
is kind of fourfold,
and I want to talk
about each one a
little bit separately.
I've harped on the
culture of collaboration.
We're going to talk about why
that's so critical to really
focus in on creating a face
to face experience and some
of the benefits that
you get from that.
I also want to talk about
productivity everywhere,
making your users
productive no matter
where they are in the world,
or what they're doing,
or what time of day.
Next, we'll take a look at
building consensus, driving
your organization in
the same direction,
and driving them towards
creative solutions in the less
debate, more create section.
And then, lastly, I want to
talk about the enterprise grade
nature of this, the quality
of the tools themselves,
and your ability to manage
it as an IT organization.
Let's start with the
culture of collaboration.
Let's be honest.
People really do not
like going to meetings.
If you've been in any meeting
that was just a conference
bridge, you look
around the table,
everybody's multitasking.
We found that up
to 60% of people
are actually multitasking in a
traditional conference bridge.
And you know, it's just
not a productive time
in terms of meeting itself.
Workers find they have
too many meetings.
And half of those they've
identified as wasteful.
And the fact is, there's just
going to be more meetings.
This isn't going away.
There isn't less meetings
than there was yesterday,
there's more.
And so as our time gets
consumed more, more meetings,
we need to make these
more productive.
And so Google approached this as
a whole new meeting experience.
We wanted video conference to
be the always thing you did.
There is no reason to
not turn on that camera
and engage in an
interpersonal way.
So we created Hangout Meet.
And we rebuilt it
from the ground up.
We improved the media quality,
so the audio and video
is much higher than what you
saw in the initial Hangouts.
We made it easy to record
and share the content
using Drive integrations.
We've increased the
size of the attendees
up to 50 participants,
and we're going
to continue to push that
boundary in the future,
and provided tools like in
meeting context and chat
integrations so that that
in-room experience is
as good as when you're remote.
And really what this
has done is allow
you to focus on the meeting.
And so it's brought people
back into the meeting.
Instead of multitasking
and doing other things,
you have presence.
People have to be a
part of that meeting.
There's a social contract
built in to being face to face.
Not only that, I'm getting
a lot more information
via body language and even be
able to cross language barriers
almost, because I'm able to
see the emotions and the face
reactions of the
people involved.
But actually, the
most important impact
is one that we
actually discovered
through a lot of research.
So Google spent a lot
of time figuring out
what makes a team successful.
And actually, you might
see a hyperlink there.
If you Google
re:Work and Google,
you'll come across a series of
studies that we did just trying
to improve our organization.
We've shared that out to
the rest of the world.
And one study in
particular, like I said,
was focused on making
successful teams.
And what we found
time and again was
it wasn't having common goals
or having strong leadership
or clear tasks defined
with timelines,
it was something called
psychological safety.
That's what made
a team successful.
And what we mean by
that is the ability
to feel safe in
sharing your ideas,
taking risks, and really
working as a team.
That's something that's
built into a video conference
culture.
And it can't be a culture
that meets on video conference
once a week for
that weekly meeting.
It's a company that meets all
the time on video conference,
that uses video conference
as the go to way
to communicate when you're
not in the same room
and creates an experience
like you're in the same room
no matter where you are.
And so I think that's
something to really highlight,
there's subtle psychological
benefits and social benefits
that come out of
this that really
make this an impactful
cultural transformation.
And with all of those, you begin
to grasp the idea of business
in real time.
And this is something,
again, that kind of
came with the rise of cloud
computing, these interconnected
systems.
that were able to update
databases in real time.
Well, that's now moved
on to the getting things
done part of the business.
And it's being able to
jump on a video conference
and tackle a problem without
having to pre-establish when
that conference
is going to be in
and set that up in
a tool somewhere,
or be in that meeting room where
we have the video conference
unit set up.
It's about just jumping
in and getting it done.
It's about doing real
time on Jamboard,
so I can share my ideas and
collaborate in real time.
I can fix, maybe, something
that somebody made a mistake on.
You know, before, I was trapped
behind the video conference
tool.
Now I can just update
that on my Jamboard,
they see the impact on theirs.
So it's about just
increasing the acceleration
of how you get things done.
Now, of course, once
you're doing this,
you need to be able
to do this everywhere.
The way you drive these tools
to be part of your culture
is by making everybody
enabled to use them no matter
where they are, if they're
at home, on the road,
or anywhere else.
And the fact is, employees
are more and more remote
as we go on.
You know, we've sort
of done the math,
and by 2020 half
of your workforce
is going to be contributing
remotely, whether that's
on client sites or touching
in from their vacations--
not something you want to do,
but something more and more
we have to do in this
ever connected world.
So we need the tools
to support that
so that things don't go off
the rails when we're not
physically in the office.
And that's really
what we've tried
to do with these
conference tools,
make them super easy to join
from a browser or a tablet
or a smartphone, make it as
simple as tapping a URL to hop
in the meeting, providing a
dial-in code at no extra charge
so that you can dial into
the meeting through a phone.
That's part of our
Enterprise Edition.
And then tying that all
into the Calendar tool
so that when I book a
room, I go in there,
the meeting's
already in that room.
Anybody added to the Calendar
gets access to the meeting,
gets access to the content
that's part of that meeting.
Really just trying to make
it as easy as possible and as
beneficial for all your users.
We worked with the
Wyoming Medical Center,
and they leveraged
this technology
to reach out to their
clinicians in remote areas,
connect those to neurosurgeons
and cardiologists,
and allow them to
spread knowledge way
beyond the walls of
their organization.
No longer did they have to bring
them in for knowledge transfer
sessions.
In the moment, when
they needed the answer,
they could jump on a Hangout
right from their mobile phone
and be connected
to these experts.
And that's really what it takes,
having a suite of tools that's
good on the go but also
in the boardroom, bridges
that gap between
remote and on location.
So with all these
tools in place,
we've got everybody
collaborating and working
together.
They're productive no
matter where they are.
The result is this
idea of consensus.
But what we found was, when
we got the video conferencing
so successful at Google, we'd
left behind the whiteboard.
And the whiteboard had
become this broken tool.
It worked great for
the people in the room.
It still worked
like it just did.
Pick up the marker and go.
But for somebody remote
on the video conference,
they'd have to play
the broken telephone
game to get that
picture corrected,
or maybe you just never got
to add their ideas whatsoever.
And, you know, we tried
hacking a solution.
I'm sure everybody's done
a few of these things,
maybe taken a picture of the
whiteboard and e-mailed that
around to everybody, or
pointed a camera from a video
conference unit at
the whiteboard--
hopefully those remote people
could see my scratchy writing
on the board--
or tried using Docs
and Sheets, which
are an outstanding
form a collaboration,
but are structured and
kind of put you in a box,
and don't allow that freeform
creativity of the Jamboard
or of a whiteboard.
And so that's why we
built the Jamboard.
We spent a lot of time
building both the hardware
and the software to make this
a wonderful whiteboard-esque
experience.
It allows you to contribute
anywhere the way you want,
and it really engages your
team to work better, no matter
where they're located.
And the first thing you're going
to notice, the whiteboard's
kind of a journey in my mind.
You kind of walk up, and
the first thing you notice
is how smooth it reacts
to the marker, how much it
feels like I actually
picked up a marker
and wrote on the board.
But then you start to notice
that this Jamboard does
a lot more than my
whiteboard used to.
It corrects my writing
when I write messy.
It doesn't need to be taken a
picture of or written "do not
erase," because it autosaves
every time I do something.
It's tied to rich content,
so I can bring images out
of a browser or from my Drive.
And it has machine learning
to correct my crappy drawings
and turn them into something
a lot more appealing.
It's connected together,
so one Jamboard
connects to another Jamboard.
If I'm working with
somebody on the other side
of the continent, I can see what
they're drawing in real time.
They can see what I
draw in real time.
It works on mobile
devices, so it
doesn't matter how
I'm connecting in,
I'm still sharing
that experience
and ideating, never
missing a creative moment.
It works great with
Hangouts, so if I
have people that
aren't near a Jamboard,
maybe don't use any Google
applications whatsoever,
they can click that Hangouts
Meet link, jump into Hangout,
see the Jamboard session, and
provide their verbal feedback.
So a great pairing of the
Jamboard and Hangouts Meet.
If they're paired
in a room they're
going to work in sync to
join the meeting together.
And maybe most importantly,
that connection to G Suite.
So G Suite offers a lot of
really great collaborative
editors.
We've added Jamboard
to that mix.
But we've also added
those editors to Jamboard.
So I can bring in a
Doc, Sheet, or Slide
to my Jamboard session, start
to annotate, add my notes,
really collaborate around
that content as well,
kind of bridging
that workflow gap.
Lastly, I want to talk
about the enterprise grade
nature of this.
And we spent a lot of
time really focusing in
on how to make these tools the
enterprise experience not only
the users needed, but that IT
needed to manage and support
them.
And so we added a lot of
enterprise grade functionality.
We took advantage of Google's
robust security posture
and really took advantage
of our scale as well.
And let's start with
the scale question.
You know, we ride on the
same network and data center
infrastructure as YouTube.
So we're able to take
advantage of that global scale
to deliver high quality video
conferencing around the world.
We've integrated this in with
G Suite in a few different ways
beyond just the integration
I just talked about.
But it begins with
your Calendar.
So when I start
Calendaring something,
it will suggest
rooms for me based
on the location of the users.
Then it will
automatically add a link
into a Hangouts Meet session.
It'll automatically add that
to the room I put it in,
so I just have to tap and go.
Really just makes
that a seamless,
frictionless experience
for my users.
When they walk in the
room, the Jamboard
will ask to join the meeting
if it's paired with the device.
If I decide to record that
session, I tap a button
and that's dropped into
my Drive for me later on.
And all of that, the devices,
the experience for the users,
and the licensing,
is all managed inside
of the Admin console
in the Cloud,
so I can easily access and
make changes in real time.
Let's take a look at some
of the hardware itself.
So this is our Hangouts
Meet hardware kit.
It comes with four pieces;
the Chromebox, which you see
on the left there, a camera--
depending on the
size of your room,
we'll talk about that in
just a second-- a Speakermic,
and a touchscreen to control
everything about the meeting.
So this would be
your in-room setup.
And let's just talk a bit
about each one of those.
This small Huddly camera
is really powerful.
It packs a big punch
for a little camera,
has a wide field of view.
It's ideal for the smaller
rooms that you have.
It'll capture
everybody in the room.
Not only that, it has
onboard machine learning.
So we've put machine learning
into the camera, which
currently enables
us to crop and zoom
to get the right perspective
for the number of people
in the room.
And we'll power
even more machine
learning as we move forward
and develop this out further.
We've also got a large
room kit as well.
That comes with a high
quality PTZ Logitech camera,
offers 10x zoom in high HD,
and also a wide field of view
there.
The Speakermic took a lot
of engineering and effort
to create a state of the
art noise suppression
and echo cancellation
experience in the room,
but also allows you to
fully control the room
from any one of the devices.
You can daisy chain these
together with a single cable
to extend it out for
large configurations.
All the updates to this
are passed down right
from the Chromebox, so I don't
even have to manage this.
As we come up with better
algorithms for that noise
suppression, they're
going to automatically get
updated into that device.
And the center of it all,
though, is the touchscreen.
And this is a really great
experience for your end users.
They don't have to
worry about how they
connect into their meeting.
They just walk in, tap their
meeting on the Calendar there.
And that's what's happening.
It's being fed from the Calendar
booking right into the room.
I can see my
meeting, tap and go.
Want to record the meeting,
I tap it once more.
Want to call a phone, I can dial
a phone number out from there,
bring up the chat that's
going on for the meeting,
all sorts of functionality
built right in there,
easy for your
users to engage in.
We've started a qualified
peripherals program
recently to just increase
the amount of customization
you can do to your rooms,
adding different cable
sets, some different
camera options,
and really just trying to
give you more options in terms
of how you build out those
more complex or unusual rooms
that you're facing.
On the Jamboard side,
we spent a lot of time
building out the
quality of the screen,
so that the touch was
really responsive,
but also you get this big
screen for a low price point.
So that took a lot of
the engineering effort,
was to make this an
easily engagable,
feel like a fluid whiteboard.
But we also took some time
and effort into the stylus
to make sure you didn't have
to have batteries in here,
so that nothing would get in the
way of you hosting your meeting
or running your meeting.
All of this is
managed, like I said,
through that centralized
administration console.
So we're bringing that all
into the Google Admin console,
where you manage your
G Suite users today.
And we're providing
you with analytics
that tell you things about
your resource allocation
and help you manage
cost control as well.
So now what I want
to do is actually
show you a little bit
about the Jamboard
and see what that
experience is like.
But just a quick
reminder that these tools
really do a few different
things for your organization.
First is to change the culture
of how you guys work together.
One of the phenomena
I have at Google
is when I've worked
with somebody
through a few video
conferences, and then I
end up meeting them in person.
And 9 times out of
10, I forget that it's
the first time I've
actually met this person,
because the video conference
experience feels so
much like getting to know them.
It just creates a tighter
work relationship.
Changing that culture
of your organization
is one of the top
benefits that you
get from using the Hangouts
Meet and the Jamboard tools.
But it also makes you
productive everywhere.
If you need to be
remote for a day,
you can easily still
interact with your coworkers
or your customers
or your partners,
using Hangouts Meet as if
you were in the same room.
Those together drive
consensus, put your company
on the same page.
And it can all be managed
through an enterprise grade
toolset to make sure you're safe
and secure and in compliance.
So with that, let's
move to the Jamboard.
Now, I'm kind of lucky today,
because I have an Android
enabled laptop, and I have
a Jamboard here behind me.
So you guys are going
to see a couple of ways
that I can interact with
both devices at once.
I'm going to jump into
my Jamboard on the screen
here, so that you
can kind of see
what it's like when
I'm editing and see
some of the editing tools
that are built into it
and all that sort of stuff.
So I'm going to do a
little bit of drawing.
On the left here,
you probably can see
I've got a whole set of tools.
And I can kind of flip
those around really easily.
It gives me a lot of power to do
different sort of interactions
with the board.
I'm going to be
using that a lot.
I've also got my friendly Undo,
so if I ever mess anything up,
I can just tap that a
couple of times and it
takes me back to where I was.
Now I want to talk to you
about the collaborative nature
of Jamboard,
because to me that's
the true power of this tool.
The fact that it does the
cool whiteboarding stuff is
great and awesome, but really
where it gets its legs,
in my mind, is when it starts
to be a collaborative tool.
But we designed it to
be easy and accessible.
And what I mean by
that is, you shouldn't
have to go through
training to use a Jamboard.
First time I saw a
Jamboard, actually,
was Bring your Kids
to Work Day, and it
was amazing to watch these
8 and 9-year-olds run up
to the Jamboard, grab
one of the stylus,
and start marking up
the board right away,
grabbing images off the
web, putting funny mustaches
on people.
And it just showed me how easy
and approachable this device
was, and also from anywhere.
Because then, when you start to
connect the Jamboard together,
you start to see that
collaborative nature.
Now, you may have noticed
that the Jamboard was
fixing my writing as we went.
That's part of the
machine learning
that's built into the tool.
So I was using
handwriting recognition
to take my messy kind
of doctor's writing
and turn that into something
legible for everybody to read.
Really cool aspect
of the Jamboard.
But I also have
a few other tools
I want show off, just
while we're here.
I can lasso things.
Each one of these is an object
that I can then move around.
In this case, I'm just going to
kind of shrink that and put it
up in the corner.
So I have that ability
to reconfigure the board,
very unlike a whiteboard.
I don't have to erase
and redraw everything.
I can just move things around.
Same with this picture
here in the middle.
I'm just going to move
it down a little bit.
Now, like I said, I want
to talk about the way
to use Jamboard as a
collaborative tool,
as an extension of the
collaboration you're doing in G
Suite and other tools today.
And really, when you see that
sort of aspect of Jamboard
best is when you bring a
second Jamboard into the mix.
So I've added a second
picture of my Jamboard
there on the screen.
And if you notice behind
me, you can see in real time
the Jamboard's updating
what's going on.
And so when I have two Jamboards
together, I can connect them,
and I begin to mirror
what's happening
on one Jamboard with the other.
So that means that
if I'm on one coast,
and I'm working with somebody
maybe out in California--
I'm in New York today--
I can share ideas.
So maybe I'm drawing the
next great idea for Google
on the board.
They can jump in, add their
ideas, extend my idea,
correct my idea, and really
turn this into a reality.
Now, you may see on the bottom
of the screen right now,
the machine learning is trying
to process and figure out what
it is I was actually drawing.
It chose a light bulb.
I can just tap that
picture on the bottom,
and it's now fixed
up my messy drawing
and, again, made
it more legible.
I'm a little surprised
it even thought
that was a light bulb,
because it was very terrible.
But you can see the power
of the machine learning
to just take an unrecognizable
kind of chicken scratch
and turn it into
something impactful.
So like I said, the
power of the Jamboards
is when you connect
them together.
But what if you're not in
a room with a Jamboard?
What if you're on
the road somewhere?
Well, we've provided a complete
toolkit of applications.
So I might want to use that
on my mobile device, my phone,
or a tablet.
Or maybe I'm going to be
connecting via my laptop.
Let's take a look at each one
of those use cases a little bit
separately.
So with the phone, it's maybe
not the ideal space to draw in.
It's a little tricky,
limited real estate.
But it is a great
place to ideate still.
I can still see everything
that's going on on the Jamboard
right from my phone.
And I do have the ability
to also add content
to the Jam session.
And one of the ways
that I like best
is by leveraging sticky notes.
And a very popular way
of solving problems today
is called Human Oriented Design,
and it leverages sticky notes
very intensely.
You kind of place them on
quadrants and prioritize
problems.
And so if I have a
great idea, I can just
type that on my
sticky note and add
that right in the Jam session.
And now I have another
asset on the screen, which
is my sticky note, and let's
just put that down there.
And I'll show it, just going
to go right from my phone
into that Jam session.
And if you're familiar
with Human Oriented Design,
sometimes it's a little
bit of a challenge
to get everybody
together for that session
or to get everybody
in front of the board,
because maybe some
people are a little shy
or there's just
too much going on.
This allows me to use my
phone as that mechanism
for participating
in the Jam session.
Really powerful way
of extending that.
Now, on my tablet, I have
even more functionality.
So the tablet actually
does everything
that my Jamboard does
in the palm of my hands.
And so I'm able to put
content onto the Jamboard,
but also see what's going on.
I basically have a
miniature Jamboard.
And not only that, but
I actually don't even
need the Jamboard at all.
I can have a Jam
session directly
with somebody on a mobile
device, maybe another tablet
or a phone.
And I can even push stuff
out to somebody on a laptop.
On the laptop, I can use
the Jam viewer to see what's
going on in the Jam session.
I can also join maybe
a video conference
and share my screen to
share that Jam that way.
Now, since we're talking about
sharing our Jam sessions,
let's add a little
bit more content.
And this is where the rich
media starts to come into play.
I've got a couple of tools
here on the left hand
side that allow me to
grab images from the web.
I'm going to grab a picture
of the Hangouts logo.
And I can just use
that image browser
to drag images right
onto the screen.
So there I've just
dragged that Hangouts logo
onto my Jam session.
But I also have a
regular web browser.
Let's look up Hangouts
Meet hardware.
Tap that link there,
takes me to the web page.
I could scroll down, maybe crop
out a piece of that web page
for marking up and annotating.
And now I have that on there.
Just position
these a little bit.
And so, like I said before,
Hangouts Meet and Jamboard are
great partners together.
I can join any Meet
as a participant
right from the Jamboard.
So that means I can
share my screen in.
I can share video
into the Hangout.
I can really participate
in that Hangout remotely,
right from the Jamboard,
but more importantly, I
can share that ideation and that
creation with any other users.
Obviously these two
can connect as well.
And it just brings everyone
together onto the same page
in the same room.
Lastly, I want to talk a little
bit about G Suite integration.
I can bring up my Google Docs,
Sheets, and Slides in Drive,
go into a folder, maybe grab
a document I want to work on,
put it down there in the corner.
Then I just double
tap that document,
and I can drag pages off.
I'm going to grab
the front page.
And then let's just get
rid of this piece here.
And notice I can
just drag stuff down
to the bottom to get rid of it.
So I've dragged a
page out of my Doc.
And I can use that to add to my
Jam session right from my phone
or from a tablet.
And we've used
mobile devices quite
intelligently to act as a
second factor authentication
to ensure that you
don't accidentally
leave your Drive
open on a Jam session
and walk away from the Jamboard.
So think of that device
as a way of securing
your content personally to you.
So I grab my Lasso here.
And let's just select
everything on the board
and shrink it down a little bit.
Because the other factor
I want to point out
is that all of this stuff
is stored in the Cloud.
And that means a few things.
First, it means I get to take
advantage of all the sharing
built into Google, right?
I can add people to my Jam,
remove people, and really
control the access to that.
It also means I get
autosave every time
I interact with the board.
Oh, and you see it got my
messy writing wrong there.
Rarely does that.
I can just stroke that out,
rewrite it, or even correct
individual letters if I want.
But the point I was
trying to make there was I
get the autosave functionality.
Every interaction I
have with the Jamboard,
automatically
saved to the Cloud.
I don't have to take a
picture of that anymore.
I also get unlimited space.
That means that if I run
out of space on one Jam,
I can just pop open the top
there, create a new tile,
maybe drag some content there,
and begin my next session.
So hopefully you
saw a little bit
about how the Jamboard
comes together.
I'll show you on here.
See how it connects
people, allows
you to create with
partners in real time,
and really how it
brings that whiteboard
into the video conference
digital generation.
That's really all I wanted to
go over with you guys today,
but we're going to move
to the Q&A session.
I know you guys have
been asking questions
throughout the session.
So we're going to
take a minute just
to kind of gather
those up, and then I'll
be right back to
answer a few of those.
All right, and we're
back for the Q&A session.
So I've got a few
questions here coming
in from my team that have
been looking at your questions
on the platform.
Just going to answer them
right from the board here.
And so first question
I'm going to grab here
is what if I want to
share my Jam session?
We've taken advantage of
the sharing mechanisms
within Google.
So it uses exact same
sharing paradigms.
I simply pop open
the side panel.
I can add people
to the Jam session,
remove people if I wanted to.
If I wanted to get rid of
Chris, here, I'd just hit the X.
And I could add anyone else.
We also have the ability to
join Jamboard to Jamboard,
just using this
little short code.
So that's another way
you could add people,
in effect, if they were in in
front of a Jamboard like that.
So great question.
Thank you.
Is the Jamboard available
in European markets?
Yes it is.
We launched in the UK last year.
We've recently announced our
launch within Denmark, France,
the Netherlands,
Spain, and the Nordics,
so Sweden, Finland, and Norway.
Thank you.
So that answers that.
More to come on that
in the future as well.
How can Hangouts Meet and
Jamboard work together?
So Hangouts Meet is
basically accessible right
from that same side panel.
So I could connect
into a meeting.
I just use the 10 digit code.
And notice there's
actually-- you probably
can't see it out there, but
there's a little camera here.
There's a mic built
into the board.
So I could actually participate
in a Hangouts Meet right
from the board,
using this camera.
Or with this little
toggle, I can
present what's on the
Jamboard into the Meet there.
Really easy to use.
Should be familiar to
any Hangouts Meet user
when they get on the Jamboard.
Let's take this one.
Is there a record
and playback feature?
Very commonly asked
for feature request.
You know, we're
working on this one,
and it definitely will
be coming down the road.
But right now, the
kind of workaround
is to join a Meet session
and then record that way.
And you can see how
the ideas came to pass
or came into creation.
Let's see here.
When will we be able
to interact and modify
Jam on the Chrome browser?
That is a coming soon as well.
We're diligently
working on this one.
This is probably the number
one request we've gotten.
And you know, there's
some logic behind this.
We just felt that this
wasn't the way to draw.
If anybody's tried
to draw with a mouse,
it is not the type
of user experience
that really works
out for people.
So we intentionally
went for things
that could take
advantage of a stylus,
or could at least
support better drawing.
And we felt the
phone and the tablet
were the right devices
for that, the phone
for the sticky noting,
and the tablet for finger
drawing and that's
sort of thing.
We are going to be releasing
an editor for the browser,
but we want to make sure we
do that in the right way that
takes advantage
of the form factor
that is a laptop or
desktop computer.
Can the Jamboard app work
without a Jamboard hardware,
i.e.
app on an app, tablet to tablet?
Yes, absolutely.
We initially thought,
hey, this is just going
to be a tablet application.
We built the whole
Jamboard application,
and every single person was
saying, I wish this was bigger.
And so it led us to
build the Jamboard
because we kind of needed that
as the companion to the tablet.
So this was the first use case.
It absolutely works tablet
to tablet, phone to phone,
or however you want
to connect and ideate.
Are there simple ways to
connect multiple people
to the Jam at once?
I kind of showed
this a little bit,
but I just want to reiterate
a couple of things,
because there's multiple
ways to connect Jams.
And I showed a couple here.
So I have the ability
to join or start
a broadcast, which means that
I can basically just give
another Jamboard user a code.
They can tap that
into their Jam session
and get that mirroring going.
I can add people, so
they'll now have the ability
to jump into the Jam.
But also right from my
phone, I can actually
locate nearby boards
and throw my Jam
onto that board from my phone.
So just using a
Bluetooth connection,
I'm able to throw a Jam
that I have onto the board.
It will just ask for a little
acceptance, and away I go.
How often does Hangouts
Meet hardware update?
Is that a manual update?
It is definitely
not a manual update.
I do not know the
frequency of the update,
so I'll have to
follow up on that.
If somebody on my
answer crew knows,
they can just throw
a sticky note up.
But it does update over the air.
So we push out the updates
to the devices themselves.
And one of the really powerful
elements of that is it also
includes qualified peripherals.
So if your Speakermic needs
updated with firmware,
we can push that right
into the Chromebox
and right through the wire
to that Speakermic, meaning
you don't have to
take care of anything.
You just let that
work on its own.
Am I able to use any of the
existing equipment with HMH?
So this is kind of a
case by case basis.
It's hard to kind of give an
overall, overarching answer.
We would recommend using
it with the equipment
that it comes with,
but we found that a lot
of speakers and mics
and even cameras
will work with the kits.
You just kind of have
to try that out yourself
and see if it works.
But in many cases, you're able
to swap in different devices.
And we are working
diligently to expand
that qualified
peripherals program
to include and encompass
more options that way.
Last one, is there a demo
or trial period for HMH?
Well, there's a couple
things I'd say to this.
We don't have an official
trial or demo program at Google
at this time.
It's something we've
discussed and are
working on and thinking about.
But definitely reach out
to your account executive,
and we can discuss
what the options are.
But the nice thing about
HMH is you don't actually
need anything more than a
browser or a mobile device
to try out the experience.
So you can try this
without all the hardware,
see if it works for you, sort
of based on the functionality,
and then decide
if the hardware is
a direction you want to go in.
So that's it for the questions.
Really appreciate everybody
taking the time today
to join us.
Thank you for tuning
in to Cloud OnAir.
Please remember, we're hosting
these live every Tuesday.
Hopefully you can
join next week.
Like I said, check the agenda.
There's a whole bunch
of different topics.
You'll definitely find
something of interest to you.
Thanks again, and take care.